good morning John it's Wednesday October
17 and I will probably recognize this
song because I think you spent about as
much time listening to it as either
maybe not quite as much
Oh
and
you
a lot of bad guys in all night
browser and you're about upon the
backpack goes that don't
but one bad guy he stands alone he will
never die
he sits upon his blocky throne it'll be
that till you die
your fingers may move with blinding
speed there may be no game you can't
beat but can't you see that no one can
defeat the man who throws the tetris
piece higher higher
no straight piece I need a mark is a
Street race
poor soul
have been a feeling like the guy throws
the tetris piece